premier vote et premier obstacle franchi
pour les démocrates et joe biden par 219
voix contre 212 le plan de relance de
près de 1900 milliards de dollars
concocté par la maison blanche a été
validé par la chambre des représentants
si de voix dissonantes n'ont pas mis à
mal la majorité démocrate
l'histoire pourrait être différente au
sénat la semaine prochaine
en cause une promesse électorale de joe
biden la hausse du salaire minimum qui
passerait de 7,25 1 15 $ de l'heure en
en pratique je ne m'implique pas dans
les règles du sénat américain
mais en matière de valeur je peux
simplement dire que nous n'aurons pas de
repos tant que nous n'aurons pas passer
le salaire minimum à 15 dollars nous
sommes engagés dans la lutte pour les 15
dollars depuis longtemps source des
tourments démocrate une personnalité
méconnue de la politique américaine
elizabeth mcdon aph
cette dernière est la gardienne des
procédures complexes du sénat une
fonction cruciale à la chambre haute du
congrès jeudi elle a jugé impossible
d'inclure cette mesure dans le projet de
loi un avis accepté par joe biden
d'autant plus que certains sénateurs
démocrates modérés ont exprimé des
réserves quant à cette mesure
al'inverse l'est la plus progressiste du
parti appelle à outrepasser cet avis
établi par une fonctionnaires non élus
de leur côté les républicains
considèrent cette hausse du revenu
minimum comme inefficace est ce constat
un rapport avec la crise du coc vide
combien de petites entreprises ont déjà
fermé à cause de cette mesure
toutes les études montrent que cette
mesure fait perdre encore plus d'emplois
regardez ce qu'il s'est passé à seattle
quand ils ont mis ce minimum en place
cela a coûté leur emploi aux personnes
qui en ont le plus besoin donc pour moi
c'est juste plus de politique et c'est
mal parce que vous savez au sénat ce
texte ne va pas sur vire une polémique
qui fait craindre à joe biden un
allongement des débats au congrès
le président américain a exhorté samedi
le sénat à une adoption rapide du plan
de relance alors que le versement des
allocations chômage doit cesser le 14
mars prochain
de son côté la hausse du salaire minimum
pourrait se trouver un nouvel adversaire
de taille en la personne de donald trump
ce week end
l'ex président fait son grand retour sur
le devant de la scène politique et
pourrait s'exprimer sur le sujet
aujourd'hui à l'occasion du
rassemblement annuel qui réunit toutes
les tendances conservatrices du pays